chex mix came to me and asked me to  review their video game  checks quest hd so i reached out to the  only expert gamers that i know  aaron blair and sonia reed aka  firefox wish i had that nickname oh  stare is  piercing you've got a giant chex mix  head  rainy never see it coming  how did that happen i zorched you right  in your stupid head and i zorched it  right  back i think if we had to rate the game  in the game  when you you fire a thing it's called a  zorcher and you zorch  each other how many zorches out of 10 do  we give this on you i used up all of my  zorches on you  if i had any left i would give it a 10  out of 10 zorches but i'm all out  you can watch our full segment on team  coco twitch  checks quest hd by chex mix  is available now with multiplayer for  free  on steam i don't understand that  sentence